Hello and welcome back to DeadTalks.
This is a video that I came up with the
idea for when I was doing my Things You
Missed episodes on Split and Unbreakable
and I was watching both movies and
noticing that there are very similar
scenes at similar points in each movie
like for example both movies began with
a birthday party scene -- well, I mean not a
party in Elijah's case but both movies
open with a birthday scene and then
there's a scene of a child pointing a
gun at an older family member at about
the same point in both movies right
before the climax. So I figured I'd watch
the movies side-by-side and see like
what other clues were left by director M
Night Shyamalan to tell us that Split is
a sequel and how it uses that same
formula as Unbreakable.
So there are a a couple different ways I could do this. I
could do it like this, where I just play
both movies at regular speed and Split
is a little bit of a longer movie so
it'll go a little bit past Unbreakable.
And the other way would be to stretch
them both so that they're the same
length like this, and that might help
things line up a little bit better
because they... I mean... both movies use
a 3-act structure formula so
similar events are gonna be happening at
the same points in each movie. But for
this for this video, I'm gonna be doing
it to where they are just both playing
at regular speed. So with that all being
said let's watch Split and Unbreakable.
*Humming Universal Theme*
So I don't actually think that things
are gonna line up perfectly. I don't
think he planned to have things line up
exactly if you put both movies on top of
each other like this. I don't think he
edited Split over Unbreakable and I think if
he had done something like that then
Split probably would have suffered for
it. But I do think that there are just
certain similarities with the plot of
each movie. "Happy Birthday!"
See we got Elijah being
born and Claire celebrating her birthday
Yeah, those two in the back seat are
watching CZsWorld videos. I got to
say this sounds pretty good with the
Unbreakable music playing over this
beginning scene and Split.
Oh! This is
gonna be so cool! Okay, I think when Bruce
Willis comes on-screen he's gonna have
his head against the window just like
very similar to about how Dennis is
sitting against the window in Split.
Wow, that's like they're both leaning back on
the headrest like that that's really
interesting.
And again there may be
things that we find that are kind of
coincidentally similar, but this is pretty similar I'd have to
say.
So these aren't lining up perfectly
but another thing that's similar about
both of these movies, is you have the
main character waking up and realizing
that they're OK after some kind of
disaster.
In the case of Split, it's her
getting knocked out by Dennis and waking
up in the holding room and then in the
case of Unbreakable he wakes up in the
doctor's office after the train accident
and that might be one of those things
that if we stretched the movies to be
the same length, that they maybe even
fall a little bit closer to each other. I
do hope that there is something at some
point, where like there's an exact frame
in both movies that looks very similar,
so that I can use it for my thumbnail.
I can just have like, "OH!:, just like a
shocked reaction.
Man watching them side
by side like this makes it look like
twice as tense twice as scary.
Oh this is
so interesting. Okay, seeing the news
report of both tragedies on the screen.
In Unbreakable it's Joseph and now right
here it's Dr. Fletcher. They don't take
place at exactly the same time but they
take place at very similar points in
each movie and I think maybe if you
count the scenes or sequences then those
events do kind of line up in terms of
their overall position.
Oh man...
That's very
much a coincidence, but Barry and David
being on the stairs at the same time.
That's hilarious.
Trying to hear the audio from both
me was at once reminds me of that time
that I watched every West Dakota video
at once.
That's weird!
As soon as she says 'if ever something
were to happen to me', he opens the
thing and it says 'how many days have you
been sick?'
But again that's not the type
of thing that I'm looking for
necessarily with this video.
Two old
ladies on the screen at the same time... Hh
my God! That is almost like too close
though
David standing in the doorway talking
said this woman, and Barry aka Dennis is
standing in the doorway talking to
Doctor Fletcher. They leave at the same
time -- are you kidding me?!
Are you kidding
me?!
This is already more interesting than
I thought.
This is the same shot! This is
insane
they're both looking through the
door in profile at the same time.
That's crazy! I'm so glad I did this this is so
entertaining.
It's the same shot. Are you kidding me?
How does that keep happening?
Both
looking down at the same angle and both
over the shoulders.
OK, this is kind of
interesting --
so in Split, we're seeing Hedwig's
drawing of the beast and in Unbreakable
we're seeing Elijah open up the comic
book and if you saw my Things You Missed,
you know that yellow guy in the comic
book page, Jaguaro, is very similar to The
Beast and I think he represents what The
Beast is supposed to be in Split. And
also pretty interesting here, we have
that upside down shot of Elijah flipping
around the comic and then the sideways
shot over there of Casey first viewing
Hedwig when she wakes up.
That's another
thing that I talked about in the Things
You Missed, so if you want to hear about
like what all that means the upside down
shots the sideways shots in both movies
go and check out those two Things You
Missed episodes. A couple of scenes after
this, Elijah talks about how comics are
like our last link to
hieroglyphics and drawings on runes and
stuff, and I wonder if
Hedwig is kind of like an emerging comic-book
artist in a way with his pictures; his
drawings of The Beasts and stuff like
that. There is a top-down scene like this
that scene in Split right now, later in
the movie when David is looking back at
his old newspaper clippings in the
closet. It's kind of a similar shot.
Yeah, this is the scene I was talking about
where we're above David and to be honest
in both movies when this shot is used,
it's because of something secret hidden
above in Split's case it's the secret
passageway through the vent and then
David is hiding his gun up there and his
old newspaper clippings.
This is kind of
interesting I was a little bit hesitant
to bring it up, but Dr. Fletcher has a
suspicion that this is not Barry,
that he's hiding something.
Right now
David has a suspicion that that guy in
the camouflage jacket is carrying a gun,
that he's hiding something.
And then
we've got Elijah saying 'do you have
good instincts for things like that?' And
Dr. Fletcher on the other side using her
intuition to make the prediction that
this is in fact Dennis not Barry.
So now Elijah is keeping an eye on this
guy as he's leaving and trying to gather
more information and Dr. Fletcher on the
other side is looking at the security
footage of Dennis leaving and trying to
gather more information. This is another
thing I thought about and I didn't
mention in the Things You Missed
episodes, but Shyamalan makes a cameo in
both movies, so is he playing the same
character in both movies did the stadium
drug dealer guy grow up and become an IT
guy in Split?
Nooo!!!
There's my
thumbnail.
Both characters suffering, both
characters lying down at this point in
the movie, both characters have basically
given up hope right here.
So this is the
Shyamalan cameo scene in Unbreakable and
earlier I was talking about; is this
the same character is the Shyamalan
from Split. Looking at it, he does
make an effort to make himself look
different, but also he's 15 years older
in Split, so obviously he's going to look
different.
But as far as the hair
style, he didn't really try to replicate
the look
from Unbreakable, so that I'm kind of
thinking that it's not the same
character.
It's kind of also interesting
how Dr. Fletcher's color is also green
as David's is, and she has like all of these
plants in the background. Shyamalan
recently posted a tweet where he talks
about the reasoning for all of his
color choices in Unbreakable, and he
talked about Green being like the color
of nature and the color of healing and
that's what I chose green for the good
guy.
It seems like every time in
Unbreakable that David talks to an old
lady happens to be during these Dr.
Fletcher scenes. I mean these two scenes
are very similar this is gonna be such a
bad juxtaposition the funniest part in
Split going over the most serious part
in Unbreakable.
Oh man...
This is kind of interesting there's two
characters facing each other talking in
profile
we have artwork in the back in both
situations. And these things may
have lined up unintentionally but he may
have had the idea for this scene based
on, 'I'm gonna compose this in a
similar way to Unbreakable and it
happened to line up.
Oh man here's another potentially really
cool reference or coincidence or
whatever you want to call it.
So she
contacts this guy on the walkie-talkie
and tells him to call the police and
this guy in the comic book store
threatens to call the police on Elijah
because he won't get out of the store.
"Call the police, I must be near you."
This is the only time that we see the
inside of Joseph's room I believe and
the only time in Split, that we see the
inside of Hedwig's room and they both
have toys in their room and stuff...
Look
at this! He's guiding her down the
aisle and the atomic the guys is guiding
Elijah down the aisle and they're both
in trouble, right?
They both noticed
something on the ground at the same time.
This is unbelievable, like... when I made
this video I thought like okay there'll
be a couple things that are similar and
they might not even line up perfectly
but there're probably some scenes that
are similar in both movies, but there are
so many crazy coincidences in this.
These
shots almost look similar. The rocks on
the right side and the trees on the left
side, and they're both talking about a
game. The Uncle's talking about the
game where they pretend that they're
animals, and she's talking about the game
where they ask each other questions.
You know, I didn't even think about this but
earlier in Split, and these don't
line up at all, it was way earlier,  but
Casey says... she tells Hedwig,
'we're like your babysitter's.' Unbreakable
has this babysitter scene...
I don't know why I brought that up but I
just thought that I would.
I always find
it hilarious how they don't even offer
the babysitter a ride.
She's just supposed to walk home in the rain.
So I
think that Elijah revealing that David
has this weakness is also like
structurally kind of in the same place
as when Dr. Fletcher writes 'say his name
Kevin Wendell Crumb' on the receipt to
reveal The Horde's weakness.
I think the scenes are gonna get further
and further apart because we're getting
towards the end of the movie, and as I
mentioned Split is longer than
Unbreakable, so at the beginning
the similar scenes structurally
are gonna be kind of close, whereas at the
end, they're gonna be a little bit
further apart, but I do think that is
kind of a similar scene in both movies
and it's kind of a trope in superhero
movies in general, where there's that
moment where the superhero's weakness
is exposed and he has to find a way to
overcome it. And then of course there's
also this scene and Unbreakable where
David is revisiting the train yard, and
that's coming up pretty soon here and
Split as well. So there may be something
to be said about Dr. Fletcher
discovering the horrible things that
Dennis and Patricia have done to these
girls, taking place around the same time
as David going to the train station and
bumping into people and discovering
all these horrible things that people
around the city have done and I think
that'll kind of come to a head in Glass,
when David eventually does have his
run-in with the Horde and sees the wrong
that he's committed in his past. It'll be
interesting to see if he bumps into one
personality of the Horde, if he's going
to see just that identity's actions or
if he's gonna see stuff that the other
identities have done as well. So here we
go it actually is gonna line up where
Kevin is at the train station at the
same time as David Dunn. And on the
whole train thing, obviously it's not
like there aren't other films that have
trains in them, you know? Even other
Shyamalan films like The Happening, they take
a train to try to get out of the
Northeast area, in The Visit they take a
train to go visit the grandparents so I
think that's kind of something that
helps cover up the fact that Split was a
sequel, because you could say, 'oh
trains it's got to be related to
Unbreakable,' but then you think, 'oh no
there's been trains and plenty of films,
and it's not really until you take
that deeper look at it that you realize
how similar
they actually are.
"It's an animal!"
So two girls locked up
inside a closet, two girls locked up
inside separate closets in Split. I
take that back this is actually a
bathroom that the girls in Unbreakable
are locked up in I believe. It looks
like David's fight with the orange man
is basically going to coincide with Dr.
Fletcher's struggle against the Beast
and structurally maybe it coincides
with Casey's fight with the Beast at the
end of Split.
I'm gonna miss Dr. Fletcher
in Glass, she's one of my favorite
characters.
And how about this doctor
Fletcher leaves that little note for the
girls and that's like she's reaching out
to the hero and giving them help, and in
Unbreakable, you've got David who is
probably gonna drown in that swimming
pool if not with the help from the girls
who throw him the pole that helped him
get out which you can see on the left
right here. And yeah I mean it's
something that happens a lot of the time
in comic books and comic book movies
where the hero is down and he seeks help
from some outside force, some other good
guy. No! That... This is crazy, this is
crazy. Okay, so Casey is gonna discover
Claire's dead body and just as David
goes to to try to help this girl, the Mom,
and discovering that she's dead as well
and they're taking place at the exact
same point in both movies. Oh what?
No!
They opened the door in sync, come on.
That one's pretty funny.
Look at these shots, they're like mirror
images of each other. This was such a fun
experiment. And, I mean, realistically
again like from a structural standpoint
him carrying the wife out and saying, 'the nightmare is over now' is
basically like the equivalent of Split,
where the guy finds Casey at the end
after the confrontation with the Beast,
and takes her out and gets her the help
that she needs.
Yeah so at this point I'm not sure that
there's gonna be anything else that
lines up because we're already past that
climax in Unbreakable, and we're kind of
just getting into it in Split. And like I
said Split is a longer movie. I think Elijah's whole speech about not knowing
your place in the world kind of
coincides with the ending scene of Split,
which we're obviously not at yet. They want
the world to know that they exist
all right so Unbreakable is now over, and
Split is just finishing up its climax
really. So there are a lot of really
interesting things, some of them
coincidence and some of them are scenes
that it kind of took the same purpose in
both films and took place at similar
spots, but sometimes the exact same spot
and sometimes similar ratio into the
story I guess. So that's gonna do it for
this video, I'm probably gonna hang out
and finish watching the end of Split,
but until next time when we're gonna be
doing a Things You Missed on Glass,
coming up later at the end of this week.
I'm very much looking forward to that
I'm very much looking forward to seeing
Glass so if you're interested in that
remember to subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week, ring
that deathbell for
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one
assuming we both survive.  Okay one more
thing.
The last line of each movie is Mr.
Glass I just wanted to add that.